a positive note from british scientists
who say they think the covert booster
can prevent another wave of hospital
admissions and deaths but doctors warn
thousands of nhs staff and patients will
need treatment for ptsd in the coming
months and of course it is the season to
be cheerful but there's still confusion
over just how cheerful we should be with
friends and colleagues we will of course
be finding out how festive the
conservative party chairman oliver
daldon is feeling in just a few minutes
time also ahead
in training for the big day the boss of
the uk santa school tells us about his
plans to make sure as many children as
possible meet the great man
i told her to take care of herself
no it's not
no it's not
and we meet british child actor woody
norman who's starring alongside your
queen phoenix in his latest film
it's friday the 3rd of december
no guilt alec baldwin says he doesn't
feel responsible for the fatal shooting
of a cinematographer on the set of his
film and accepts his career may be over
do you feel guilt
no no someone is responsible
for what happened and i can't say who
that is but i know it's not me
a boost from the booster scientists say
they believe a third clover jab can
prevent illness and death
meanwhile confusion continues over how
we should celebrate the festive season
as a leading government scientist says
he wouldn't feel safe going to a
christmas party
stranded british holidaymakers stuck in
redless countries because there are not
enough hotel quarantine rooms in the uk
i do hereby declare that louis thomas
french is duly elected as the member of
parliament for old bexley and syd cup
still true blue the conservatives
retained their seat in old bexley and
syd cup but with a hugely reduced
majority
waiting to be reconnected around 16 000
people are still without power this
morning nearly a week after storm iron
and weather milder with some rain bushes
will turn colder again over the weekend
[Music]
ali good morning alec baldwin says he
doesn't feel guilty about the fatal
shooting of a cinematographer on the set
of his film rust he says the weapon he
was holding fired at helena hutchins
without him pulling the trigger the
actors said he accepted his career could
be over but didn't care our u.s
correspondents greg milan reports
she was someone who was loved by
everyone who worked with and liked by
everyone who worked with and admired
[Music]
alec baldwin is still haunted by the
death of helena hutchins the
cinematographer he shot and killed on a
movie set we have two entries from a
movie done
shot
okay we're getting them out there
already to stay on the phone with me
how it could have happened is still a
mystery to investigators and it's clear
from his first interview since the
shooting baldwin himself he says he was
told the gun was safe i let go of the
hammer the gun the gun goes on well the
trigger wasn't pulled i didn't pull the
trigger so you never pulled the trigger
no no no no i would never point a gun at
anyone and pull a trigger at them never
it was some time before he realized what
had actually happened
the notion that there was a live round
in that gun
did not dawn on me till probably 45
minutes to an hour later 45 minutes to
an hour how that live round got there is
the focus of the investigation someone
put a live bullet and a gun a bullet
that wasn't even supposed to be on the
property last month lane looper told sky
news he'd left the film because of
concerns about safety this set was
unsafe
simply because they didn't have the
wherewithal to
you know follow you know safety rules
that we have in this industry that we've
been following for decades baldwin said
he'd never raised those concerns with
him and denied corners had been cut he
has though considered giving up acting i
couldn't get my career anymore is it
over but why well it could be is this
the worst thing that's ever happened to
you yes
yep
do you feel guilt
no someone is responsible
for what happened and i can't say who
that is but i know it's not me alec
baldwin says he doesn't expect to be
criminally charged over the shooting but
six weeks on like everyone he's still
waiting for answers greg milam sky news
los angeles
now there still seems to be a fair bit
of confusion over just how much we
should indulge in festive spirits in the
run-up to christmas with more mixed
messages over whether it's safe to
attend christmas parties well let's
speak to the conservative party chairman
oliver dalton who joins me here in the
studio thank you very much indeed for
your time here hi good morning so let's
just um look at some of the stories
that's coming out some worrying data
that's coming in this morning then
regarding the omicron variant of course
a new variant latest findings from south
africa show that it could cause a
substantial wave of infections
and evade immunity how worried are you
then about this and if this is the case
does it mean that title restrictions
will be coming into place
well first of all the government takes
this very seriously and i can understand
that your your viewers and you will be
concerned about this new variant that's
why we've introduced a range of new
restrictions already which we think are
proportionate for example in relation to
travel and in relation to mask wearing
that's why we analyze the the virus and
that's happening for example at port and
down now
but in the meantime the message to
people i think is
uh fairly straightforward which is keep
calm carry on with your christmas plans
we've put the necessary restrictions in
place but beyond that keep calm and
carry on it's interesting you say carry
on with your christmas plans this is
exactly what the prime minister boris
johnson's also saying saying go ahead
with your christmas parties if you so
wish but actually jenny harris who's of
course the head of the uk health
security agency says that people should
cut back on unnecessary socializing over
the festive period but on the other hand
the prime minister's saying go ahead and
party on so
it seems that you're out of step then
with what the scientists are saying
well well all of our
advice is based on scientific evidence
and indeed the the chief medical officer
and the chief scientific advisor attends
cabinet music cabinet when we discussed
this earlier this week that's why we've
gone for this balanced and proportionate
set of measures so it is the case that
unlike previously in england people will
have to wear masks on public transport
and they'll have to wear masks in retail
settings we've very much timed out the
border restrictions but beyond that
uh we believe that those are necessarily
appropriate steps but beyond that people
can carry on with their plans as before
so i would say to people just keep calm
carry on with your christmas plans as as
already set out but this morning we're
just learning that actually quite a
large number of organizations a few are
cancelling their plans and people are
not listening to what you're saying do
you think that people are just not
trusting what you're saying they just
don't have much confidence so in what
you're saying so some of the people
we're hearing university college london
nhs trusts age uk these are all
organizations government departments
that have cancelled their christmas
parties despite the fact that you're
saying carry on
well i understand that people have um
concerns around the new variant that's
why the government has taken the sort of
measures that we've
already outlined but but beyond that as
the prime minister has been at pains to
say several times and said again
yesterday and i'm very happy to
to repeat again this morning we think
those are sufficient at this stage and
beyond that people should continue with
their plans as intended
we've always said that we want people to
have a better christmas than they had
last year we're confident they're able
to do so but the reason people are able
to do so is because of this vaccine so
the one thing that everyone can do if
they're worried is to make sure that
they take that booster that they make
sure that they top up their immunity and
for example the results out this morning
are very promising about the effects of
that booster they vindicate the decision
taken by the government to invest in
buying those doses of pfizer and
modernist so provided people take the
booster when they get the call provided
they abide by the existing rules as as
updated in light of the the new variant
i think people can continue with their
christmas plans and i'd encourage people
to do so well talking about the fact
that um a number of government
organizations have decided to cancel
their christmas party this is certainly
having a knock-on effect financially on
the hospitality industry which has
already taken a huge battery during this
pandemic are you going to provide any
support for them during this winter
months well we we've already provided a
huge amount
i think the the support that we've
outlined and by the way some of that
support is is ongoing still for example
in relation to to business rates been
businesses are still benefiting from
that
beyond that we have not changed the
advice around people uh taking part in
hospitality so going to the pub going to
restaurants and so on and actually i
think most pubs and restaurants up until
very recently have been doing very well
during this season and we're not
discouraging people from continuing to
do so they are going to take a hit there
if a lot of people are canceling their
christmas um you know plans they will be
taking a huge hit a lot of people had
been
relying on this christmas festive um
season to make up some of the losses
that they've made they've made over the
years so
will you provide extra support for them
during this christmas period well let's
wait and see how we we do over the the
christmas period because the
government's position remains that
people should carry on with their
christmas plans and
i understand why your viewers and and
why people up and down the country will
be concerned about this new variant i
want to reassure people that that is why
we have taken the measures in relation
to to travel that's why we've tightened
some of the rules around mask wearing
but why we're taking a proportionate
approach whilst we consider
the effects of this this variant
and by that i mean that the
uh port and down and others are
examining this for us to understand
exactly it's its implications whilst
that's going on we believe these are
neces these are appropriate steps
they're sufficient for now to enable
people to continue with their christmas
plans as before okay now we're just
hearing of families who are being
stranded in south africa obviously it's
on the redless country and this is
because they're not
enough hotel rooms for them to
quarantine in when they reach the uk so
it looks like a lot of people will be
spending their christmases in those
southern african countries which you
have put on the red lists and it appears
that you put the restrictions in place
overnight but you didn't readjust or
look out for the capacity for the
existing infrastructure plan
well we do have to take the risks
associated with this new variant
seriously and i don't want to impose any
restrictions the government doesn't want
to impose any more restrictions than
necessary but because of the uh origins
of this virus in southern africa we had
to move rapidly to
impose those restrictions on south
africa that's why we did it
immediately of course we'll make sure
that the appropriate
facilities are in in place for people
but the reason why we did that and the
reason this whole strategy is about
making sure that we limit uh the spread
of the omnichrome omicron variant at
this stage whilst we we look at the
effects of it which in turn enables me
to be able to say that people can keep
calm and carry on with their christmas
plans because we're taking tough
measures in relation to the virus coming
into the country through at-risk
countries so you have enough rooms
available then if people in southern
africa are wanting to come here and to
isolate in hotels will there be enough
hotel rooms for well of course there's a
difference in the between um
nationals of southern african countries
who are not allowed to come here uk
nationals
who are returning yes of course we'll
make sure that we we have appropriate
provisions so those people who are
stranded we can say to them come home
it's absolutely fine
the minister says there will be enough
rooms for you yes so
so what i say to those people is clearly
they have to abide by the new rules
which means that when they return they
have to immediately hotel quarantine
they have to have their pcr on day two
and day eight and of course we will make
sure that there are
appropriate hotel quarantine facilities
in place we ramped those up last time
and we'll make sure we continue to do so
okay well let's step away from covenant
and let's talk about the by-election
which is taking place in old bexley and
sid cup their 10 swing to labor now this
is supposed to be a safe tourist seat 10
is nothing to be sniffed at
well look this is a good result for a
governing party midterm as you well know
governing parties shouldn't expect to do
well midterm we actually secured over 50
of the vote in in bexley and i pay
tribute to our excellent candidate and
the campaign team there that secured
that result this idea that that labour
have made some surge ahead is is really
for the birds they've actually got about
the same vote share as they secured
under jeremy corbyn in 2017 and kirsten
couldn't even be bothered to turn up to
the the by-election so i'm i'm i'm
really not terribly worried about labour
the fact is they did make some some
gains there and one of the things that
kept coming up um was the allegations of
sleaze which is what kept coming up on
the doorstep do you think that that's
something that's had a bit of a knock-on
effect on your numbers well of course
people have concerns uh mid-term with uh
any government's performance and of
course people have been concerned about
what's happened over the past couple of
months but i actually think it's tribute
contrary to a lot of expectations to the
campaign that has been fought uh by
louis french by the the excellent team
down there that we secured 50 of those
now what i take from that is the
government has to focus and get on with
delivery that's why for example just
next week we'll be taking action to
address one of people's concerns around
small boats with a new nationality and
borders legislation that will come
before parliament again and i very much
hope that labour and the liberal
democrats will actually support that
legislation because it's essential to
tackle this problem the turnout was very
low wasn't it it was only 34
yes i mean it is the case that in
by-elections turnout tends to be low but
against that backdrop we we managed to
secure 50 and i really want to thank the
people of bexley for putting their faith
in louis and putting their faith in the
government let's talk about the french
prime minister then rejecting boris
johnson's call for joint uk french
patrols in the channel
we have a crisis here don't we and the
two people who should be coming together
to solve this are just not getting along
where do we go from here
well there's two elements first of all
we need to get our laws in the right
place so they're not currently fit for
purpose and that's why we're bringing
forward the nationality and balls is
built for example which will uh increase
to a maximum life sentence for those
vile people traffickers who are
exploiting vulnerable people crossing
from one safe country france to another
safe country the uk it has a range of
other measures for example in relation
to increasing the sanctions for
illegally entering the uk so it's
essential we get that through and it's
essential by the way we get support from
other parties for that when that comes
before parliament next week we also have
to have international cooperation now
the home secretary has already this week
has been meeting i believe with her
dutch counterparts and with her italian
counterparts to stop this flow of
migration and we continue to cooperate
with the french we cooperate with the
french many different ways including in
uh in in nato uh in relation to uh joint
intelligence operations so there's a lot
of anglo-french cooperation going on and
actually if you look we have managed
through that cooperation to stop 20 000
boats crossing the channel i hope that
cooperation will continue
do you think that the allegations of
fleas and also the crisis that we're
seeing over the migrants who share in
the um in the channel will haunt you
when it comes to the next election
general election well i think it's
essential that we address the uh
challenge of of migrants uh the the um
the small boats but that is precisely
why we're bringing forward this
legislation to toughen up our laws next
week so the challenge is will other
parties support us in that legislation
will the liberal democrats enable
supporters in that legislation when it
comes before parliament next week
olivier dowden chairman of the
conservative party thank you very much
indeed for your time thanks very much
well let's take a look at how the papers
are covering covert this morning
and the times leads with research which
suggests that booster jabs massively
strengthen the body's defense against
covert it says that the data raises
hopes of beating the omicron variant
with a third jab increasing antibody
levels 30 fold
now the mirror has a message to the
conservative party about festive parties
with a headline make up your mind on
christmas it criticizes what it calls
extreme of mixed messages with torrey
senior tories about whether parties can
go ahead
they shouldn't be cancelling the express
quotes boris johnson saying he's urging
families to carry on with the christmas
celebrations and his resistant calls to
tighten restrictions over the festive
period
and metro understands that 152 people
were fined 200 pounds each for not
wearing masks on public transport in
london on the first day of tightened
rules
so some mixed messages in a fight
against covert 19 british scientists say
they are increasingly confident that
coveted booster vaccines will offer good
protection against different variants
well meanwhile senior doctors say that
the nhs may need to treat nearly a
quarter of a million people for
post-traumatic stress as a result of the
pandemic
the really important thing is to try and
get help before you lose your
self-esteem you lose your relationships
and maybe lose your job and we know that
if you can get help early on then
actually many people with ptsd recover
and they get themselves back to fitness
and they carry on with their lives and
that's something that was in the past
and actually waiting until you had a
crisis until things are falling apart is
not really a good way of approaching
this sort of problem
well the latest data shows that 53
945 new cases of covet 19 have been
recorded in the latest 24-hour period
a further 141 people have also died so
this brings a total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test to 145
281
26
028 people received the first dose of a
vaccine while 32
356 people received their second days so
this brings a total number of people
who've received their second dose to
more than
46.4 million
and 407
851 booster and third jabs were given in
the latest 24-hour period taking the
total number of those doses to just over
19 million
what's guys aisha zahid is on carnaby
street in central london for us now i
said good morning to you looking very
festive there but not many people there
behind you obviously it is very early in
the morning as well isn't
it yeah that's right but i'm sure
carnaby street will be filled with
christmas shoppers later today over the
weekend over the coming weeks all
wondering what exactly is going to
happen over the festive period it's
something concerning hospitality venues
the sector wants to make up for the
losses that it made last year but at the
moment bookings are down they're seeing
cancellations now we've heard from one
of the government's leading scientists
professor peter openshaw he's a part of
nerve tag the subgroup of sage he has
said that he wouldn't feel safe going to
a christmas party this year and that's
down to the omicron variant but also
because the chance of becoming infected
is too high it's a sentiment echoed by
the british medical association they say
stronger measures should be enforced
they want to see the government
encouraging people to avoid large
gatherings they want people to meet
outdoors where possible but at the
moment government is saying that
christmas will continue as normal boris
johnson said it will be considerably
better than last year
aisha thank you
still to come on the show
after half past seven i'll be discussing
the big rise in homophobic and
transphobic hate crimes since the end of
lockdown with campaigner and journalist
benjamin butterworth
also this morning why doctors are
expecting to treat thousands of covert
patients for post-traumatic stress
disorder
and later we'll discuss the results of
the old bexley and sid cup by-election
with labour's national campaign
coordinator
shabana mahmoud
now the conservatives have retained
their seat in the old sitka bexley and
sid cup by-election overnight but with a
significant reduction in their majority
their candidate louis french won with
just over 11 000 votes followed by
labour on 6700
the reform party formerly the brexit
party picked up just short of one and a
half thousand votes
here we can see the share of the vote
for the conservatives holding just over
half the votes at 51.5
then labor with just over 30
and let's see how the votes has changed
since 2019 and that share of the vote
for the conservatives is significantly
down by 13 points while labour was up
seven points along with gains for the
reform party and the greens our chief
political correspondent john craig
reports
and i do hereby declare that louis
thomas french is duly elected as the
member of parliament for old bexley and
syd cup
relief for the tories after they held
this by-election in southeast london
with a majority over labor of just under
four and a half thousand
old bexley and sibcup's new mp his local
councillor louis french i'm absolutely
delighted to become the first homegrown
mp for our local area it's been it's a
great privilege you know i'm deeply
honored to be wearing the the ribbon of
james broken shoe my late friend i was
asked by the family to do that it's a
great one to be doing so you know to get
over 50 of the vote in a in a december
election you know by-election with the
government in place you know it's a
great result for us and we're absolutely
delighted with the result
on a low turnout of just 34
the conservatives majority was slashed
from 19 000.
the tory's share of the vote was down 13
and labors was up seven and a half
percent this is the seat that has always
been uh tory stronghold is the tory
heartland and actually what we've seen
tonight is a swing to labor of over 10
and you know that's a that's a great
result for us in in tory in tory
heartland
labour fought this by-election focusing
on allegations of tory
and the personal conduct of boris
johnson
the conservatives will be mightily
relieved to have got this by-election
out of the way albeit with a reduced
majority and reduced share of the vote
all the parties have made a quick get
away from old bexley and sidcup that's
because the by-election roadshow moves
on to north shropshire in two weeks time
and that could be a much tougher battle
for the tories
here in south east london the
by-election was caused by the death of a
much-loved local mp james brokenshire
shropshire north however will be fought
against the background of former mp owen
patterson's breach of commons rules and
allegations of mps for hire
john craig sky news south east london
also making the news this morning
a father and stepmother are due to be
sentenced later today for killing a
six-year-old boy
after subjecting him to months of abuse
emma tustin was convicted of murdering
arthur labino
hughes last year while his father thomas
hughes was convicted of manslaughter
a quarter new york has heard how jeffrey
epstein's former housekeeper drove two
underage girls to the financials house
under glenn maxwell's orders
juan alessi said he took maxwell's
alleged victims to epstein's palm beach
estate when both girls appeared to be
around 14 or 15 years old
france has rejected britain's offer of
police and soldiers to patrol the
coastlines to deter migrants crossing
the channel in a letter to boris johnson
the french prime minister says that the
country cannot accept the idea because
it would compromise the nation's
sovereignty
the oil company shell has pulled out of
the controversial combo oil field
development west of shetland the company
had a 30 stake in the project but said
the economic case for investment in the
north atlantic project was not strong
enough
a british teenager has been seriously
injured in a crocodile attack in
southern africa
emily osborne smith from andover
hampshire was white worm was white water
rafting with friends in zambia when the
crocodile bit her leg and dragged her
underwater she's now being treated in
hospital for serious leg injuries
so what about the web then let's see how
things are shaping up
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well today looks briefly milder with
some rain around but the cold and
showery theme will return over the
weekend it's a murky and damp start
across england and wells with more
general rain in the south and the chilly
east now any snow falling there will be
temporary and unlikely to settle as
milder air moves in most other places
though are dry england and wells will
stay rather cloudy through the morning
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
keep calm and carry on with your
christmas plans that's the message from
the
government this morning many government
departments are reported to have
cancelled their festive events well last
night a senior government scientist said
he wouldn't feel safe going to a
christmas party this year but the
conservative party chairman oliver
daldin told us that people shouldn't
cancel their christmas plans
all of our
advice is based on scientific evidence
and indeed the the chief medical officer
and the chief scientific advisor attends
cabinet was at cabinet when we discussed
this earlier this week that's why we've
gone for this balanced and proportionate
set of measures so it is the case that
unlike previously in england people will
have to wear masks on public transport
and they'll have to wear masks in retail
settings we've very much tightened up
the border restrictions but beyond that
we believe that those are necessary
appropriate steps but beyond that people
can carry on with their plans as before
so i would say to people just keep calm
carry on with your christmas plans as as
already set out
well let's bring in our political
correspondence rob powell who joins me
now so rob keep calm and carrying on is
that message being heeded by people yeah
oliver dowden saying essentially that at
the moment they believe that their
response is proportionate in terms of
face masks and shots on public transport
and the rules um around travel and
quarantine
and other than that people should just
carry on as normal i think the
difficulty is though when the government
is saying that this variant um is
perhaps concerning in terms of getting
around immunity and transmissibility and
then on the other hand is saying but
people should carry on as normal then it
leaves people i guess in a difficult
position where they have to sort of
gauge the risk um on their own and that
means people come up with different
decisions and that's why we're hearing
from some hospitality businesses about
christmas parties being cancelled it's
why we're hearing from some public
health
experts that are adopting a more
cautious tone like people like jenny
harry's from the biosecurity center and
one scientist speaking last night saying
they wouldn't be comfortable going to um
a christmas party ultimately i think a
lot of this is down um to personal
judgment and the difficulty for the
government is they don't yet have enough
hard fast facts about how much of a risk
this new variant poses and until they do
know that i think they will be reluctant
to go any further than they are at the
moment rob thank you
now police across the uk say there's
been a significant rise in homophobic
and transphobic hate crimes since the
end of the lockdown
official figures show the number of
offenses reported each month reached
more than 2 000 in the summer well we're
now joined by journalist and campaigner
benjamin butterworth thank you very much
indeed for joining us here on sky news
and good morning to you now looking at
those figures is absolutely staggering
just shocking really
what do you think this is down to is it
a case that we're seeing more people
feeling comfortable with coming forward
and reporting these crimes
well good morning i think it's certainly
very concerning you know we've seen a
rise in lgbt hate crimes over a number
of years and these latest figures are
not only more than 2020 during lockdown
but they're even more than 2019 before
the lockdowns and covert came into force
i think you're right to point out that
some of it will be that people feel able
to go and report these crimes you know
turn the clock back 10 15 years to when
this law first came in for lgbt hate
crimes and most people probably didn't
trust the system but i also think what
you might be seeing is lots of people
who are reporting things that happen
during the pandemic we know that many
young lgbt people were forced to go back
and live with family members who were
abusive who were homophobic and
transphobic but also people have been
locked up in their communities maybe
with neighbors that are like that and so
that's been a real concern
what i hope that from seeing these
figures is that people realize that gay
and bisexual and transgender people
still face this kind of abuse all the
time you know even though these figures
are shocking and even though some of it
will be an uplift in reporting because
people feel safer to report
it's still a fraction of the reality
you know a couple of years ago someone
threatened to stab me for being gay and
i reported that and that person
eventually got prosecuted but there had
been so many other times when i just
been walking down the street you know
not even holding hands with another man
maybe just having been on night out or
being in a gay village in manchester or
london and have faced abuse
and we need people to recognize that
this is a problem and that the
government and police forces need to
help lgbt people
i mean if you're holding hands with
another man perhaps the person who
doesn't like it will probably mind their
own business that's one thing but let me
just pick you up on what you said
somebody threatened to stab you what
happened there
so i was on a train back from brighton
pride a couple of years ago and someone
got on a croydon train station on the
way back into london and they said that
it was unchristian that it was a threat
to his children
to be gay for homosexuality to be around
he compared me to a pedophile and he
said to this carriage full of gay people
i'll stab every one of you now i have
never felt fear like it this man was
behaving in a way that implied that he
had a knife in his pants and i was very
very scared about what he'd do
now you know what was very difficult was
that lots of people on that train didn't
go and give statements to the police
after the incident partly because they
were scared and wanted to forget what
happened and partly because they weren't
sure that there would be a prosecution
come from it the prosecution rate for
lgbt hate crimes is actually very low
and when i took it to the police i have
to say they were excellent the
metropolitan police however they did say
that the crown prosecution service often
drops the lgbt hate crime part of
of attempted convictions because it
makes it harder to get a conviction of
any type in this case for threatening to
stab me and so when i went through that
experience not only was it incredibly
concerning for me but it says that a lot
of these crimes actually aren't reported
properly because the police encourage
people and the cps say that it's not
really worth it
my goodness i think the message here i
hope is that if these things happen just
keep reporting it isn't it and i think
hopefully we will see some change there
benjamin thank you very much indeed for
your time here on sky news this morning
thank you thank you
now labour says covet quarantine
facilities in the uk are chaotic and
it's accusing the government of failing
to provide basic infrastructure british
holiday makers have been left stranded
in redless countries because there are
not enough hotel quarantine rooms
available here as helen ann smith
reports
arriving home shouldn't be hard
but for some now stuck in redless
countries it's proving worse than they
could have possibly imagined
this is what they can expect a bus to 10
days in a quarantine hotel
but that's if they can book a room there
aren't currently enough and it's left
people stranded
teresa's originally from south africa
she's been visiting her mum for what she
fears may be the final time she was
meant to return next week but she can't
get a hotel room until december the 22nd
she now faces christmas in quarantine
this turbulence of the booking and the
flight changing and then arranging
finding out where you get your pcr tests
and driving you know 10 miles to go and
book it
it takes its toll you know you force
people to do something but allow them to
do it
and the cost is crippling for families
like hannah's they must now pay
thousands of pounds not just for the
hotel but potentially to move their
flights to fit around the limited
availability it's made my mom very ill
she's extremely stressed i can't really
highlight enough not only the
incompetence of not having enough hotel
rooms for travellers coming back but the
incompetence of their booking process
it's dire it's truly dire
ten countries were added to the red list
very fast with little warning it means
quarantine capacity is less
this hotel is one of many that was being
used to quarantine red list arrivals but
isn't any more a sign perhaps just how
much smaller the operation is this time
this chain offered eight hotels last
time they now have just three made ready
by a huge team effort no mean feat says
the owner we have to get special uh
equipment in we've got to make sure
uh even from a room service point of
view so a lot of planning goes into it
and you know especially in the current
climate when you can't even get all your
deliveries in on time
the government says it's monitoring
things and adding to capacity but these
problems say some were predictable so i
like it when the government reacts
swiftly to a fast developing problem
what i don't like is when they don't
think around corners and they're not
prepared for the unprepared and that's
exactly what we've got here
the booking company says it's helped
thousands of travellers and recent
flight cancellations haven't helped this
part of a trip is rarely enjoyable but
for some right now it would be a relief
helen and smith sky news heathrow
let's take a look at what's happening in
the world of sports with jackie
wow calm down johnny it's only a game
brought to you by vitality sharing the
benefits of healthy living
manchester united's new interim manager
ralph rannick starts work today after
watching his new side win a five-goal
thriller against arsenal last night well
he was in the stands to see arsenal take
the lead at old trafford
through one of the most bizarre premier
league goals you'll ever see goalkeeper
david o'hare was accidentally injured by
his teammate fred and before the referee
could stop the game emile smith rowe
fired the ball
into the net
the game was level at half time bruno
fernandez finishing off this united
attack
then came two goals in as many minutes
at the start of the second half first
cristiano ronaldo with another landmark
goal to put the home side in front that
was his 800th career goal
but arsenal were level again quickly
martin odergaard equalising to make it
2-2 with this
[Applause]
but
as on so many occasions ronaldo proved
to be the match winner again united were
awarded a penalty after var intervened
for that foul by odigod on fred
ronaldo scoring from the spot to claim
the victory
rang nick now takes charge of united for
the rest of the season and after the
game it was confirmed that michael
carrick would leave the club
[Applause]
tottenham were up to sixth after a two
nil home win against brentford these
sides were playing each other in the
league for the first time since 1949
as sergey kanelson goal put spurs in
front
and antonio conte's side wrapped up the
win midway through the second half a
quick counter attack finished off by
human song
tottenham are now only two points
outside the top four
celtic have cut rangers lead at the top
of the scottish premiership back to four
points they were one-nil winners against
hearts
anthony ralston's low cross turned in by
japan international kyogre for hashi
that is three league wins in a row for
celtic
roy mackerel has made a strong start at
gulf's world hero challenge in the
bahamas he opened his tournament with a
six-under par first round putting him in
a three-way tie for the lead this chip
in at the 14th for eagle
mcelroy is top of the standings
alongside daniel berger and abraham
answer
that is all the support for now see you
in an hour's time with more
handball handball
handball ref handball
jackie thank you very much indeed see
you in an hour's time now anyone who has
a chance to relive a little bit of
christmas film history
the original house from the 1990 film
how home alone will be available to rent
on airbnb during the festive period
that's quite exciting actually i don't
know how i feel about that the online
site has announced people will be able
to rent the mcallister's home in chicago
for one night only there it is there how
rather exciting are those effective
colors as well on the 12th of december
up to four guests will be able to stay
in the house for just 19 pounds that's
it i'm packing my bags i'm heading over
there right now does anyone know which
particular parts of your body can be
damaged by air pollution
[Music]
friday morning will be rather murky and
damp for england and wales with more
general rain in the south and east
slowly clearing into the windy southeast
most other places will be dry with some
brightness but northern and western
scotland will see a few showers it'll be
milder for most
the afternoon we'll see rain returning
to the southwest while showers develop
more widely in the far northwest
looking at the uk's air pollution levels
will remain low measuring just two or
three on the daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now senior doctors say the nhs may need
to treat nearly a quarter of a million
people for post-traumatic stress
disorder as a result of the pandemic the
royal college of psychiatrists say both
covert patients and healthcare staff
will probably suffer from the condition
well joining us now is neil greenberg
who's professor of defense mental health
at king's college london an expert
editor of new patient resource at the
royal college of psychiatrics thank you
very much indeed for joining us here on
sky news this morning just very firstly
looking at those figures
very stark numbers there 230 000 new
cases potentially in england alone as a
result of the pandemic how did you
arrive at these numbers
um well good morning so actually the
data actually comes from the nhs itself
from the strategy unit and what the
royal college has done is to produce
some expert guidance to try and help
patients understand when they should
seek help and also you know what
post-traumatic stress disorder is um but
it's important to say that
ptsd post-traumatic stress disorder
isn't just
something that happens during the
pandemic we know that many people in the
uk have suffered with ptsd anyhow but it
is very likely that frontline staff such
as those working in intensive care on
the spiritual wards or in the ambulance
service or in social care and also
people who have had really severe coping
and been admitted to hospital they're at
increased risk of suffering with this
condition and it's really important that
they get the right care
so this is obviously the remnants that's
coming on from the pandemic that we've
had so this is going to be more people
needing care and having to rely on the
nhs
well that's that's true the nhs
absolutely provides care for for people
who have ptsd it's fair to say that
sometimes if you go and try and seek
care in some areas it can take you a bit
of time to
to actually get the care that you need
but what we do know is one of the really
important um
things with trauma is to
try and prevent people uh needing this
sort of care in the long term and we
know that having really good support in
the workplace um and trying to use
active coping strategies makes a big
difference to people who've been exposed
to trauma it's absolutely not the case
that everybody who goes through a
traumatic event suffers with ptsd it's
an important minority that do but we we
shouldn't um over exaggerate uh the
threats but at the same time we don't
want to not provide care for people who
absolutely need care for this condition
it doesn't bode very well does it if the
staff members and the nhs that we rely
on are actually going through a
difficult time and you talk about the
fact that people in the health service
are experiencing ptsd and you also
obviously mention um other members of
the public as well just tell us what's
led to this particularly for the nhs
workers what is it that has contributed
to this condition
well i think for nhs workers and also
those working in social care settings um
this has been a really challenging 18
months to two years so it's it's fair to
say that healthcare workers and social
care workers unfortunately are are not
um
unusual for them to find that that
people die in their care because that's
what happens when people go into those
sort of facilities but as we know there
have been very
strong pressures upon staff who haven't
been able to deliver the care they want
to do this is often referred to as
what's called a moral injury and the
moral injuries are where you um get
yourself in situations where um you
can't do what you want to do so you you
may have not delivered ideal care you
may have not delivered uh care at all
because you weren't able to be
in two places at once and these more
unethical challenges can really impact
upon people's mental health um and
that's why we think that it's likely
that going forward there will be a
substantial number of healthcare and
social care staff who do need
professional help the good news is that
the nhs has invested in what are called
well-being hubs and these are
psychological support facilities within
nhs trusts across the country and the
idea of these is that they'll provide
quick access to nhs and social care
staff so that they don't have to wait uh
for a long time because it's not only
morally right that we look after them
because they've looked after us we also
need to make sure we keep them at work
because they're going to help the
country recover in the long term
so looking at the large number of people
then who are likely to be suffering from
this
how challenging is it going to be then
to get a diagnosis
well um it can be a challenge i think
the first thing to say about about
getting a diagnosis and help is many
people who have this condition don't
necessarily recognize it and those who
do recognize it often feel very
reluctant to go and seek help and they
kind of feel that it's not something
they should do you know they're in a
caring role themselves they shouldn't be
taking up resources
and many of them also afraid it might
impact upon their career or their
ability to to to work where they want to
um and so what i think the the nhs and
social care settings need to do is to is
to try and engender this idea of it's
okay not to be okay and to be fair there
has been a lot of work trying to move
towards a culture where it's it's
acceptable you know perhaps for some
even expected that they might suffer
with mental health difficulties and what
we want is a future where people can go
and get care quickly um get better get
back to work and get on with their lives
rather than suffering in silence and
then not getting care until everything's
falling apart when a crisis happens
neil greenberg professor of defense
mental health at king's college london
thanks for your time this morning
thank you thank you
well let's check in on the weather now
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well the good news is today looks
briefly milder with some rain around but
the cold and showery theme will return
over the weekend so not so good news
there it's a murky and damp start across
england and wales with more general rain
in the south and the chilly east any
snow falling there will be temporary and
unlikely to settle as milder air moves
in most other places are looking dry
england and wales will stay rather
cloudy through the morning but the rain
will largely clear to the windy
southeast elsewhere it will stay mainly
dry with some brightness in the north
but northern and western scotland will
see a few showers more rain will reach
southwest ireland by lunchtime and it
will be milder than yesterday